Guten Morgen Tim.
Ihr habt gehört, unsere Freiheit wird doch nicht an der Firewall verteidigt, sondern im Cyberraum.
Ja, aber erst, wenn wir gelernt haben, wie wir Angriffswellen von einem Schiff abwehren und wie wir eine Firewall um ein Feldlager ziehen.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Nummer eins eins sieben. Ich bin, ich darf jeder eins, sieben, sieben, was habe ich gesagt?
Eins eins sieben.
Eins eins sieben habe ich gesagt, das ist natürlich total falsch und ich behaupte das Gegenteil. Äh hundertsiebenundsiebzig und äh ich darf wieder mitspielen. Das ist schön. Ja, aber eine schöne Sendung habt ihr da gemacht. Der Thomas und du.
Der Thomas hat eine schöne Sendung gemacht, ich saß daneben,
Aber wir haben ja, wir haben ja, wir haben ja ganz viel viele lustige Sachen vergessen in in der Sendung zu erzählen und ähm die möchte ich jetzt irgendwie kurz am Anfang einfach mal alle loswerden, weil
was ja passiert ist, wir sind ja jetzt wir sind ja jetzt Mainstream, nee sind wir doch wir sind jetzt Mainstream.
Du meinst wir jetzt hier, äh, Lokbuchnetzpolitik ist zu mir gestream oder Netzpolitik als solche.
Eher die Hooligans gegen Geheimdienste.
Ja, das äh kommt aus unserem Fundus, ne?
Die Aufkleber, die wir letztes Jahr beim Camp verteilt haben, haben es offenbar irgendwo auf die Toiletten
die von so illustren Persönlichkeiten wie Eisfeld äh besucht werden. Eisfeld für diejenigen
die nicht ganz so alt sind wie Tim und ich, der heißt heute Jan Delay und trägt einen Hut und singt Musik
und der hat äh unseren hat unser hat einen so einen Aufkleber von uns gefunden und ihn getwittert und gesagt, Top Ding.
Wir wir freuen uns natürlich äh über.
Schleife, ne?
Ja, wir freuen uns, wir freuen uns. Leider ja doch, dass wir freuen uns, ja. Ähm.
Ja, wir freuen uns einfach.
Genau und dann dann haben wir eine quasi fast eine müssen wir von der letzten Sendung etwas ergänzen.
Und zwar ist wohl bei einigen äh Hörer Hörern und Hörerinnen der Eindruck äh entstanden als gäbe es mit der Gründung des C drei W jetzt.
Endlich oder erstmalig oder einzig äh wie der Chaos in Österreich und das äh stimmt gar nicht.
Ähm denn der die neu gegründete C drei W.
Ist die ehemalige Chaosnaher Gruppe Wien und es gibt noch mindestens bevor ich jetzt wieder einen Fehler mache. Äh einige andere,
Städte in Österreich, in denen es Chaos in Form von Erfahrungsaustauschkreisen oder äh Chaos-Treffs gibt, darunter Salzburg, Graz, Linz und Innsbruck. Da gibt's nämlich auch Chaos,
Und die,
Salzburger haben wir jetzt auch gerade erst den Easterhack ausgerichtet, den ich übrigens besucht habe und der eine unglaublich äh schöne Veranstaltung war, von der ich äh mehrere schöne Vorträge äh empfehlen,
kann werde und möchte.
Ja genau, also die Chaosnahegruppe Wien, das das kenne ich auch noch, das war so, sagen wir mal so der frühe,
erste Ansatz so ein bisschen ans Chaos äh Umfeld anzudocken, was ich glaube ich damals auch noch, sagen wir mal, in seinen äh in seinen Strukturen noch dabei war, zu finden,
Und ich glaube, das war auch so einer der Beweggründe, warum man da jetzt nicht gleich ein CC oder Erfolgreis oder was auch immer ausgerufen hat, weil äh sich der Club da selber noch nicht so ganz so sicher war, äh wie den Essen alles zusammenpassen soll,
gepaart auch mit so einigen historischen Belastungen durch,
ähm euphorische Ausrufe von CCCs im Ausland.
Die ähm streckenweise ein bisschen in die Hose gegangen sind. Vor allem ist da,
das Experiment ein Experiment in Frankreich äh zu nennen, wo äh das Ganze im Prinzip so einen Geheimdienst Honi Pott gewesen ist, ja? Das heißt, da wurde mal so ein bisschen CC ausgerufen und äh stellte sich halt heraus, dass das eben.
Weg kommt, ja?
Der Versuch war äh da eben sozusagen Leute in den Honigtopf laufen zu lassen.
Das kam dann irgendwann raus und war natürlich nicht so schön und das war so.
Ähm ja einer der Gründe, warum wir dann auch immer so etwas grundskeptisch waren, was so jetzt so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Supranationalen äh äh Rollout des äh der Marke CC äh betrifft, ne.
Aber was Österreich betrifft, mache ich mir da ehrlich gesagt jetzt wenig Sorgen, ähm das war ja auch schon immer äh und ist wahrscheinlich auch immer noch im Meterlapp angesiedelt, ne, genau.
Genau ist aber nicht das Meterlob. Also das.
Nein, nein, das Meterlapp ist ja nur ein Ort, das habt ihr ja auch, habt ihr ja auch gesagt, das weiß ich auch. Meterlapp ist nur ein Ort, äh das Mieterlapp ist allerdings auch nicht nur irgendein Ort, sondern wirklich ein,
toller Ort, den ich immer äh sehr gemocht habe und auch von seiner Gründung weg mitbekommen habe.
Um mich jedes Mal wieder äh beeindruckt, wenn ich da bin und es ist äh absolut nachvollziehbar, dass das Chaos natürlich dort dann andockt.
Ja,
Salzburg, wie gesagt, auch sehr gutes Chaos, äußerst gutes Chaos mit mit dem Easterhack hier sein, sein Chaos,
sehr schön unter Beweis gestellt, dass wir wirklich eine eine echt nette Veranstaltung und ich habe das ja jetzt ähm.
Selten ja, dass so bei, dass ich bei Chaosveranstaltungen einfach mal nur so äh hingehen kann und das hatte ich jetzt,
dieses Ostern fast, also ich hatte, ich musste einen Vortrag halten, um
noch eines der ausverkauften Tickets zu kriegen, aber das hätte ich natürlich auch gerne gemacht, den kann man auch auf Media CCC DE anschauen. Das war
Vortrag übers übers Trollen und das ist jetzt inzwischen schwieriger geworden ist und was äh Trollen,
Es ist in einer Welt nach AfD und Trump äh noch Trollen möglich. Ähm da wird der mache ich mir so langsam erste Gedanken drüber.
Ähm aber so diese kleinen Chaosveranstaltungen kann man wirklich äh enorm ähm empfehlen. Also einfach auch aufgrund dieser
Familiarität und dieser kleine dieser kleineren Späße, die dann eben da auch einfach im Kleinen und angenehmen Kreise stattfinden, was weiß ich so, Roboter, Wettkämpfe, ne, muss man Roboter bauen und dann die Roboter gegeneinander äh antreten lassen, was hatten wir da einen Spaß
wirklich viele amüsante Vorträge insbesondere hier
Leira und McLemon sind da hervorzuheben. Die haben glaube ich drei oder vier
echt interessante Vorträge, also amüsante und interessante Vorträge gehalten. Äh drei äh über technische Themen und einen über die äh C drei W.
Und äh auch sonst glaube ich ist da echt ein cooles Programm zusammengekommen
und deswegen möchte ich bei dieser Gelegenheit ganz unüblich mal zu beginnen
auch weil wir heute technische Schwierigkeiten haben, die Melodie einzuspielen, mal die äh Temperatur Space Invasion in Innsbruck äh empfehlen, die vom ersten bis dreizehnten April im freien Theater stattfindet
und da vom IT-Sendikat ausgerichtet wird, dann haben wir die
Kryptocon vom neunzehnten bis zweiundzwanzigsten Mai in Leipzig, da vom Sublab ausgerichtet, auch eine äh Konferenz jetzt glaube ich mindestens zum dritten Mal stattfindet.
Und dann natürlich auch schon Klassiker unter den CCC-Veranstaltungen, die ähm Gulasch programmieren macht am Frohenleichnamswochenende, also vom sechsundzwanzigsten bis neunundzwanzigsten Mai
in der äh Hochschule für Gestaltung und dem Zentrum für Kunst und
Medientechnologie in Karlsruhe. Also die drei Veranstaltungen sollten auf jeden Fall auf der Liste sein, wenn ihr.
In der Nähe dieser Städte wohnt und wenn nicht dann eigentlich auch also echt so kleine CC-Veranstaltungen,
große, große Spaß.
Ja ist immer wieder ist immer wieder zu empfehlen, ich schaff's, schaff's leider äh viel zu selten in letzter Zeit, das ist überhaupt gar keine böse Absicht, aber es äh es ist immer etwas verhext und ähm.
Jetzt auch Easterhack konnte ich leider äh nicht kommen. Ähm.
Und werde aber gerne gewesen, habe allerdings aus der Ferne einiges äh Gutes gehört über wie das dort insgesamt auch alles aufgezogen und gestaltet war und wie sich da die Orga engagiert hat.
Kannst du das soweit bestätigen.
Das war wirklich cool. Also eine also Salzburg erstmal eine tolle Stadt, so als Berliner ist man ja immer überrascht, wenn man irgendwo hinkommt, wo sich äh die Einwohner in irgendeiner Form äh Mühe geben,
Stadtbild in irgendeiner Form zu erhalten oder zu gestalten. Das ist man ja in Berlin einfach überhaupt nicht gewöhnt,
und äh das ist also da sehr äh sehr beeindruckende schöne Stadt. Äh nette Leute, die hatten auch mit dieser Arge Kultur in der Stadt fand echt eine eine coole Location.
Und ähm man geht ja äh jetzt auch ohne.
Also man geht natürlich zu so einer Veranstaltung, die in so einem kleinen Rahmen stattfindet und die von Leuten gemacht wird, die das vielleicht.
Wo der größere Teil der Gruppe das vielleicht auch zum ersten Mal macht, ja ähm,
schon mit einer mit so einer Nachsichtigkeit hin, ja, dass man so denkt sich, ja, das muss jetzt auch nicht alles,
laufen, das ist ja auch völlig klar und äh das war aber das Gegenteil war der Fall. Also die haben eine eins A Versorgung, das war alles wirklich professionell und beeindruckend und in einer schönen Location, einer schönen Atmosphäre
Das war ein rundes Ding, wirklich schön. Und natürlich auch, also ne, coole Leute da, das war einfach von vorne bis hinten schön.
Erfreulich.
Ja und dann haben wir ja in der, hast du das im Intro ja schon gerade angesprochen. Ähm,
Das ist jetzt schon irgendwie seit zwei Wochen oder so, läuft das irgendwie
aber das ist mir, ich hab's die ersten zwei Wochen nicht geglaubt und deswegen mich nicht getraut, dass in der äh in der Sendung zu bringen, weil ich immer noch dachte, dass ich irgendwie äh dann Leute irgendwo schrecklich lachen, dass ich doch drauf reingefallen bin.
Aber es gibt tatsächlich eine äh Bundeswehrkampagne,
für für die die Abteilung oder die äh die ja den den Armeeteil oder was ich kenne mich da nicht so aus. Äh digitale Kräfte.
Und ähm wir erinnern uns an die
Lokbuchnetzpolitik folge einhundertfünfzig oder was das war beim Camp, äh wo andere ja schon darüber gesprochen hat, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt halt langsam in den Cyberkrieg ziehen will. Und wir erinnern uns insbesondere an äh Lokbuchnetzpolitik einhundertneunundsechzig mit dem Titel
unsere Freiheit auch an der Firewall verteidigt.
Ja
Und man hört uns eben auch bei den Kameraden und entsprechend lautet jetzt der Slogan dieser digitalen Kräfte oder einer der Slogan ähm,
unsere Freiheit wird auch im Cyberraum verteidigt und ich hab lange gezweifelt und lange überlegt aber ich glaube die meinen das ernst.
Ja natürlich meinen sie das ernst.
Ich würde sogar auch der der Bundeswehr ein Stück weit äh here, Ziele unterstellen wollen.
Also mag mag auch etwa in unseren Kreisen etwas unpopulär sein. Ich würde der Bundeswehr an sich für ihre Ziele unterstellen
wollen und ähm finden nicht alles ähm nicht alles grundsätzlich bedenklich, was sich da in den letzten ähm fünfzig, sechzig Jahren äh an Geschichte abgespielt hat,
Trotzdem ist natürlich diese äh Einmischung in den digitalen Raum ähm einfach,
schwierig, wenn man äh sieht, wie sehr sich der Staat bisher mit den ganzen ähm,
Angelegenheiten aus Digitalien beschäftigt hat, ne. Das ist halt alles noch Neuland.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich bin ähm ich kann mir vorstellen, dass vielleicht bei der Bundeswehr Leute arbeiten, die äh.
Oder ich bin mir sicher, dass dass da Leute bei der Bundeswehr arbeiten, die von dem Guten ihres Tuns überzeugt sind, äh würde aber auch über die letzten fünfzig oder sechzig Jahre der der Bundeswehr in ihrem Wirken jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein positives äh Zeugnis ausstehen, wie du, aber das ist eigentlich auch egal
Ähm ich habe wenig Lust mir mit anzuschauen, wie,
jetzt dieses schöne Internet, was wir uns da irgendwie mal gebaut haben und als irgendwie die,
die das ein so schönes, großes Freiheitsversprechen hatte
welches wir jetzt ohnehin schon aufgrund wirtschaftlicher Interessen dahinscheiden sehen, ähm, mir jetzt auch noch anzuschauen, wie dieser Bereich irgendwie militarisiert uns zu zur Kriegsstätte erklärt werden soll
Äh gleichzeitig bin ich aber natürlich auch mit mit dieser Erfahrung jetzt seit äh einigen äh Jahren schon äh.
Vertraut.
Weil ich jetzt gerade irgendwie mir diese Seite ansehe und denke, also bevor die irgendwie in Cyber-Award ziehen können, müssen die erstmal irgendwie jemanden finden, der ihnen das Curning bei den Fonds irgendwie mal repariert,
Das äh das macht mich ganz ganz irre. Ja, da werde ich ganz, da verliere ich direkt den Faden.
Ähm ja, also.
Halt das, also ich habe da einfach keinen Bock drauf, ja? Auf Krieg im im Internet, ja? Und es ist
aber natürlich möchte ich an der Stelle auch anmerken, dass das eben auch nicht eine ob nun Krieg im Internet stattfindet oder nicht, ist auch nicht eine Entscheidung, die die Bundeswehr allein trifft
sondern eine, die alle Nationen treffen, ähm und die einige Nationen dieser Erde,
offenbar auch schon vor zehn Jahren getroffen haben, wenn wir uns an,
verschiedene, wenige Beispiele der äh der digitalen Kriegsführung oder digitalen Angriffe auf andere Staaten,
mal anschauen. Äh insofern natürlich muss ich dann leider offenbar auch diese Bundeswehr in in diesem Bereich ähm,
engagieren. Als nicht als Freiwilligenarmee äh bin ich dann mal gespannt,
ob sie in der Lage sind, da entsprechendes Personal für äh diesen Bereich zu begeistern. Ähm.
Da ja gerade diese IT-Security-Branche eigentlich dafür bekannt ist, dass sie.
Ähm jetzt keine Probleme hat, Leute äh ohne äh Studien oder Schulabschluss äh zu beschäftigen und das ja ähm,
Als Karriereoption ja immer eben auch einer eines eine der äh Bereiche war, durch die der
Durch die die Bundeswehr ähm wenn nicht
Elitepersonal äh dann immerhin Personen einer besonderen Ausbildung zuführen konnte und das weiß ich halt nicht, ob das im IT-Sicherheitsbereich der Bundeswehr auch gelingen wird,
ja mit mit diesen Angeboten und mit insbesondere mit dieser Werbekampagne, ja? Also ich mein
wir wir beobachten in den USA seit ja auch mindestens sechs oder zehn Jahren 'ne sehr starke Tendenz der IT-Sicherheitsindustrie in den
ähm ja äh nationalen Sicherheitskomplex, der mehr oder weniger am Ende dann halt dieser militärische ist äh oder der Geheimdienstliche,
und äh wir sind ja können uns glücklich schätzen in Deutschland diese äh Bewegung noch nicht zu haben,
Und ähm ja, also ich beobachte diese Entwicklung mit allgemeiner Sorge.
Aber natürlich auch mit so einem mit so einem Unwohlsein in in Anbetracht dessen welche ja militärische Macht andere Staaten.
Im Bereich der IT.
IT-Sicherheit, IT-Unsicherheit, Angriffe, Sabotage, Spionage äh schon entwickelt haben.
Ja, da ist auf jeden Fall ein wetteres.
In Anbetracht dieser völlig plumpen Kampagne.
Auf jeden Fall ein Wettrüsten im Gange.
Und das ähm ja das finde ich jetzt nicht so überraschend, dass auch die Bundeswehr sozusagen darauf einsteigt. Ich meine, die werden wahrscheinlich irgendwie auf ihren ganzen Militärkonferenzen äh das einfach die ganze Zeit um die Ohren gehauen bekommen.
Auch auf internationaler Ebene. Uns ist ja klar, dass sie sich dazu dann irgendwie positioniert. Was jetzt die Werbekampagnen betrifft. Ich meine, ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht genau, genau, wie wen sie damit jetzt eigentlich ansprechen wollen. Ähm wahrscheinlich suchen sie einfach hindering nach Personal.
Was halt sich überlegt, ob's irgendwie unterbezahlt bei der Bundeswehr arbeiten will oder hochbezahlt im IT-Bereich, ne.
Ja genau, das ist net, also das ist echt ein Problem. Ja, also also bevor du dich da als IT-Soldat bewirbst, ähm da kannste schon wirklich.
Ja, dann na gut, aber da muss ich halt auch sagen, so lieber.
Ich finde, also ich finde das halt auch teilweise.
Lieber, die da sagen, ich tue mal was für einen Staat
ähm und ich äh engagiere mich sozusagen jetzt hier für die Gesellschaft. Ich blümel das jetzt hier mal so ein bisschen auf, ja? Ich schildere das jetzt in in rosigeren Farben, als man das wahrscheinlich auch noch sehen kann.
Ähm als ich schließe mich mal den nächsten Bot Gang an, ne.
Ja, wenn das die Alternative ist, also ich meine im Moment ist dieser IT-Sicherheitsbereich ja durchaus einer, in dem man ähm ja, also,
lass uns das ich weiß das ich hab halt auf diese auf diesen gesamten Teil kein Bock. Also ich hab ich hab ein Problem oder ich möchte eigentlich nicht diese Meditation des
des Internets sehen.
Aber ich kann natürlich auch äh wenn Meditarisierung des Internets Nummer ist, dann äh möchte ich mich natürlich auch nicht hinstellen und sagen, dann soll die äh die Bundeswehr aber bitte nicht mitmachen,
ne, dann ist ja dann auch schlecht.
Ja. Na ja, ich glaube, äh brauchen wir jetzt, das brauchen wir.
Aber sagen wir so, einigen war uns einigen bei uns auf den Grundkonsitzen. Mit der Kampagne bitte nicht. Also so viel können wir, glaube ich, sagen.
Ja, schon gar nicht mit unseren Sendungst.
Also wenn Cyber kriegt, dann nicht so.
Tja, wie machen wir denn sonst den Cyber-Krieg?
Wir machen den Cyberkrieg über, wir machen den Cyberkrieg über Amazon Wunschzettel und Amazon Affiliate Links. Ähm.
Ich habe da ein Konzept entwickelt und ähm ich habe auch schon echt gedacht, ich werde jetzt hier Opfer des Cyberkriegs geworden, weil ich irgendwie seit gut drei Monaten äh irgendwie keinerlei äh Pakete mehr bekommen habe und ab und zu
kommt ja dann doch mal eine kleine freundliche Aufmerksamkeit und dann wurde ich jetzt mal darauf hingewiesen, dass ich offenbar die äh Versandadresse äh gelöscht habe
an die ähm ich eigentlich immer diese Pakete bekommen habe. Und wenn jetzt jemand versucht hat, mir über Amazon eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit zukommen zu lassen, äh dann hat Amazon gesagt, ja wunderbar, können wir aber nicht dahin schicken.
Und ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt gefixt. Darauf wollte ich nur nochmal hinweis.
Ach so, also du bist jetzt bereit sozusagen für neue Geschenklawinen.
Ich bin bereit für neue, also ich bin bereit, neue Gaben entgegenzunehmen.
Ja, okay, das äh das freut mich für dich.
Und ich ich möchte auch bei dieser Gelegenheit nochmal auf den Affiliate-Link hinweisen, der, der auch eine sehr coole Aktion, ein sehr gut, da musst ihr gar nichts, da könnt ihr einfach für euch was kaufen und ich kriege einen
ein Teil davon ab, also von dem Erlös, nicht von dem von dem Gerät, was ihr euch dann kauft. Das ist, die habe ich beide nochmal da, so und so.
Ja, du weißt auch, dass die Leute alle sowieso schon den Mieterebene Affiliates Linkmarkt haben.
Ja, da müssen die halt mal ihre Cookies löschen.
So wird nämlich der Cyber War geführt. Der Cyberware, da geht's um Bitcoins.
Mein Wunschzettel oder dein Wunschzettel.
Ja, also das ist ja ganz klar, welcher hier der Wunschzell der Herzen ist. Ähm da müssen wir nicht.
Natürlich. Das weiß jeder. Da kannst du jetzt noch so viel quatschen.
Werde Spender bei der Wunschzellwehr.
Wollen wir uns mal über richtige Themen unterhalten und nicht nur über diesen ganzen Geld verdienen? Aspekt, über Cyberkriege und Wunschzettel.
Ich verdiene kein Geld, ja. Ich habe kein Geld. Ich mache nur Cyber-Ohr. Ähm ja, wir könnten über, über Geld ausgeben reden.
Ja, in welcher Form? Für iPhones. Ja, das können wir machen. Das äh aber ist das nicht eher ein Thema für die.
Ja, diese diese ich meinte jetzt auch nicht, die dieses äh dieses wirklich erbärmliche Apple äh Releasefest da, sondern den äh diese Apple Versus FBI Geschichte.
Ja, ne, die ist ja nach wie vor interessant, auch wenn sie jetzt äh offiziell als ähm,
vorbei deklariert wird. Zumindest versucht das das FBI, das FBI hat ja äh jetzt mal von sich hören lassen und ähm,
gesagt, na ja, hier die anstehende Anhörung und so weiter, das äh vertagen wir jetzt mal
weil es ist ja der eigentliche Grund weggefallen, nämlich der ähm in den Medien ja nun seit Wochen breit postolierte Anspruch, dass sie doch bitte äh von Apple mal ein Telefon geöffnet bekommen
möchten, nämlich dieses Telefon, dieses besagte iPhone fünf C, was ähm,
dem San Bernadino Attentäter zugeordnet war, wohl aber eben der Gesundheitsbehörde eigentlich gehörte.
Und dort wollten sie halt irgendwelche Daten haben, auch wenn sie nicht genau wussten, was sie sich davon versprachen. Auf jeden Fall äh ist dieser Fall ja nun in den letzten Wochen lang und breit, auch hier diskutiert worden und nun ähm,
Haben sie aber,
auch ohne die Hilfe von Apple Vollzug gemeldet, also sie sind der Auffassung, dass sie jetzt eben das Ziel, was sie eigentlich mit der Unterstützung von Apple erreichen wollten, selbst erreicht haben, beziehungsweise es gibt auch Gerüchte, dass sie das
in äh Zusammenarbeit mit einem,
israelischen Unternehmen äh gemacht haben, die sich zumindest medienwirksam da breit aufgestellt haben und gesagt haben, oh ist kein Problem. Wir wissen Bescheid. Warum hoppt uns nicht gleich angerufen? Wir machen euch das Ding auf.
Ähm ja, jetzt ähm ist sozusagen diese ganze Geschichte, die ja äh auch wirklich enorm eskaliert ist,
in der äh in der Öffentlichkeit, in der amerikanischen Öffentlichkeit natürlich auch nochmal angeheizt durch den Wahlkampf. Ähm Apple selber hat ja wirklich alles.
Zum Einsatz gebracht eigentlich, was was ihnen so zusteht bis hin zu äh ein, zwei Minuten äh zu Beginn der Verkündung ihres neuesten,
iPhones und iPads, also in dieser besagten Keynote letzte Woche und das ähm ja mag vielleicht jetzt nicht sonderlich überrascht haben, dass sie das getan haben, aber insgesamt war ist das natürlich schon so eine Sache, dass sie eben.
So ein rechtliche Auseinandersetzung thematisieren in einem Event, wo es eigentlich um Produkte geht.
Also genau, das war einerseits das Besondere und andererseits ähm ich meine Apple.
Hat sich ja dagegen gewehrt, in diesem Einzelfall, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist der Dammbruch,
das FBI hat vermutlich diesen von mehreren hundert Einzelfallfällen gewählt, weil sie damit den Dammbruch forcieren wollten.
Und quasi den an den Punkt kommen wollten zu sagen yo,
hier jetzt haben wir den den Präzedenzfall und jetzt äh geht's weiter. Also das war ja das, worum es eigentlich ging. Und als ich
zeichnete in den Erstgutachten der Richter und Staatsanwälte und so weiter das.
BI sitzt so einfach nicht kriegen würde, was sie da vom FBI äh vom äh von Apple wollen.
Scheint sich hier das FBI mehr oder weniger aus der Affäre gestohlen zu haben, indem sie dann eben sagen, alles klar? Dann holen wir uns das jetzt von jemand anderem
So, dann dann waren wir unser Gesicht in der Angelegenheit und meiden die gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung, die eigentlich sehr viele ja gerne gesehen hätten, also äh unter anderem Apple.
So, ich ticke auch, dass Apple ähm sich da sehr
in einer nicht unbedingt in einer sicheren, aber doch zumindest in einer, einer, einer guten Position gesehen hat, das alles anzugehen, zumal es ja auch schon äh Teilentscheidungen in anderen ähnlichen Fällen gab, gerade vor ein paar Wochen, die schon in die Richtung gewiesen haben. Also es gab eigentlich, glaube ich, niemanden, der wirklich der Meinung war, dass das FBI dort gut aufgestellt ist.
Vor allem glaube ich so meine ich das jetzt rausgehört zu haben und jetzt links liefern zu können,
es ging so die Einschätzung auch herum, dass das FBI sich auch einfach extrem vergalopiert hat und das auf mehreren Ebenen. Erstmal haben sie sich den falschen Gegner gesucht. Sie meinten zwar.
Apple wäre jetzt mal das richtige Target, weil eigentlich eine angesehene Firma, die ähm
immer von ihrem guten Image lebt und äh die alle lieb haben und ja super äh bei den Customern da steht, die wird sich ja wohl äh äh nicht auch im Traum nur äh ansatzweise dagegen wehren können
da mitzuhelfen, weil sie ja äh so viel Image zu verlieren haben im Prinzip,
Ja, das Gegenteil war richtig, Apple hat sich enorm auf die Hinterbeine gestellt und hat im Prinzip auch alles in die Waagschale geworfen. Also das muss man auch sagen, ich meine, es gab ja immer diese Vorwürfe mit, das machen sie jetzt nur aus Marketinggründen.
Das halte ich wirklich für total absurd, weil aus Marketinggründen glaube ich, hätten sie genau sich anders verhalten,
Das ist sozusagen das, wo das Marketing immer sagt, so, nee, so ne Sachen wollen wir überhaupt nicht in der Öffentlichkeit sehen und hier mit Terroristen, Support und so weiter in Verbindung gebracht werden.
Das ist das Schlimmste, was uns passieren kann. Und es gibt auch so Umfragen, wo im Prinzip so dieser View, dass Apple, die Guten sind, äh extrem nachgelassen hat
So, trotzdem haben sie das halt durchgezogen. Und das finde ich an der Stelle auch ähm ziemlich bemerkenswert. Trotzdem, du hast Recht,
Sie hätten wahrscheinlich das auch ganz gerne jetzt äh weiter forciert, weil sie sich da eben ähm auf der richtigen Spur sehr äh sahen.
Das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht stattfinden. Trotz alledem ist glaube ich die Diskussion ähm schon sehr,
weit gedient, also das FBI ähm
hat einfach, glaube ich, auch deshalb so ein bisschen den Rückruf bekommen, auch aus dem Inneren des Staates
weil einfach auch niemand bereit war, mitzuziehen. Also ich meine
Obama hat so ein bisschen rumschabenzelt und irgendwie so ominös gesagt, na ja, man könnte ja mal vielleicht und so, aber dass da jetzt da wirklich eine Position bezogen hat, ist äh definitiv nicht der Fall
Und außerdem glaube ich auch, dass so Gruppen wie die NSA, et cetera, ähm,
einfach überhaupt nicht mitgezogen sind, weil die sowieso gar kein Interesse daran haben, dass das FBI im digitalen Bereich irgendwie äh äh nennenswerte Rechte oder Kompetenzen zugesprochen bekommt. Die sitzen da und sagen, na ja.
Wir können das eh ne? Sozusagen, aber die NSA ist im Prinzip dabei.
Innerhalb der USA eben diese an vielen Stellen eben die Rolle des FBI auch zu übernehmen, das sind auch einfach Machtkämpfe, die an der Stelle stattfinden.
Ja, also das heißt, ist einig ist die Situation für alle Beteiligten uns unzufriedenstellend. Ähm,
die Öffentlichkeit weiß nun, dass es irgendwie gelingt, so ein iPhone fünf C aufzumachen. Ähm man kann aber nur darüber spekulieren, weil das FBI nicht
äh dazu verpflichtet ist, dass jetzt in irgendeiner Form zu erklären, wie sie's gemacht haben. Ähm die.
Es gibt wenige Buchmattmacher, die Wetten annehmen, dass es tatsächlich John McAfhy geschafft hat. Ähm.
Tatsächlich äh vermutet man eher, dass es äh darum geht,
dass also quasi der der Speicherchip dieses alten Systems wo es eben noch keine Secure Endlave gibt, dass man den in irgendeiner Form manipuliert hat, dass sich das Gerät einfach nicht mehr merken konnte, wie oft ähm.
Eingegeben wurde. Also wenn man äh wenn man quasi ein System hat, das runterzählt, ja und einem eine gewisse Anzahl an Versuchen gibt, äh dann gibt es verschieden
tief verschieden, stark invasive Möglichkeiten. Ähm diesem System eben das Zählen abzugewöhnen oder dieses System
der Möglichkeit zu berauben, sich das zu merken, also zum Beispiel, indem man
den Strom wegnimmt oder bestimmte Leiterbahnen durchtrennt, also ist dann immer unterschiedlich, aber quasi mehr oder weniger der Angriff hat vermutlich darüber funktioniert
dem iPhone die Möglichkeit zu nehmen, sich zu merken, wie oft der äh die Code-Eingabe fehlgeschlagen ist. Das ist so die,
der wahrscheinlichste äh die wahrscheinlichste Art des Angriffs, die jetzt hier eine Rolle spielt.
Aber das sind alles Spekulationen, da gibt's bisher weder Wissen darüber, wer es war, äh noch äh wie es gemacht wurde und ähm vermutlich äh während die sich auch,
davor hüten, das jetzt irgendwie zu veröffentlichen.
Ja, man muss auch noch dazu sagen, das iPhone fünf C ist jetzt so die Vor-Vor-Vor vorletzte Generation so, also sind so irgendwie so drei neuere Modelle
mittlerweile auf dem Markt und die die nächste Generation steht vor der Tür und wird sicherlich dann im Bereich Security auch nochmal enorm nachlegen. Das wird ganz spannend zu sein zu sehen, was äh was sie da jetzt noch äh drauflegen werden und dass sie da was drauflegen werden, glaube ich, steht vollkommen außer Frage.
Ich fand.
Ich finde, finde aber diese ganze Debatte immer noch sehr interessant und ich denke auch, dass die äh noch wach gehalten werden sollte. Zuletzt, als es jetzt sozusagen noch nicht so weit war, dass sie das diese Anhörung einstellen und sich im Prinzip auch alle darüber Gedanken gemacht haben,
der Staat, Gesetze,
verabschieden, die solche Unternehmen dazu verpflichten, eben diese Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Die eigentliche Forderung war ja, schreibt uns mal spezielle Software.
Ne. Apple sagt, das ist eine Backdoor, wie man auch immer das nennt. Der eigentlich interessante Punkt äh für mich an der Stelle war.
Darf ein Staat eigentlich einem Unternehmen vorschreiben, was es mit seinen Produk,
auch noch zu tun hat, damit das irgendwie in seinem Sinne läuft.
Also es stand ja sozusagen, also das Damoklesschwert war äh wir zwingen euch jetzt euch Apple als Unternehmen,
folgende technische Maßnahmen zu umzusetzen für uns,
G laut Aussage von Apple, das äh finde ich auch glaubhaft. Schon so mehrere Mannwochen, wenn nicht sogar mehrere Mannmonate in Anspruch genommen hätte. Was einerseits Geld kostet, andererseits Zeit kostet, aber vor allem auch interessant.
Ja auch Mitarbeiter braucht, die denn bereit sind, das auch zu tun. Und es wurde halt ähm vielfach ähm gemunkelt,
ob denn das nicht dazu führen würde, dass dann diese Mitarbeiter einfach bei Apple kündigen und sagen.
Uns auch egal zu was ihr da verpflichtet werdet. Ich bau das nicht ein. Ich ich versau mir nicht hier meine Security Reputation,
weil damit bin ich dann irgendwie durch auf dem Markt, dann gehe ich einfach irgendwo anders hin,
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich hier mit meinem kryptologischen Basiswissen und meinen Programmierfähigkeiten und meinem Deep Inside äh wie das bei Apple alles so läuft äh Schwierigkeiten hätte, ein gut bezahlten Job zu bekommen.
Und das ist natürlich schon ein ziemlicher Hammer, ne? Weil man stellt sich jetzt mal vor, äh die würden dann tatsächlich eben so ein äh so eine Anweisung, wie auch immer das dann äh äh heißen mag
dadurch reichen und Tag später ist Apple seine Security Abteilung los. Ich mein dann ist einfach mal alles im Eimer.
Ja, also das kann auch eine Rolle spielen, ja.
Ne
Na ja, also ich denke äh das FBI hat sich hier einfach übernommen und ähm sie wurde einfach schon seit Längerem von allen Seiten auf eine Exit-Strategie hingedrängt und die haben wir jetzt gesehen.
Ja. Ja, ja, ja. Aber ähm man kann jetzt auch echt, also ich meine, es wäre naiv jetzt so davon auszugehen, dass ich dieses Thema jetzt erledigt hätte. Ähm,
Apple wird einerseits jetzt dafür sorgen, dass sie äh die Endpoint äh Security in den zukünftigen Gerätegenerationen halt so hochziehen
unter Umständen gar keine Hilfe mehr gibt in einem solchen Fall. Der Preis, den sie dafür zahlen ist dann eben auch das Nutzer, die ihren Pascot vergessen haben ähm erledigt sind.
Genau, weil die gehen dann in den Apple Store rein und sagen, hier Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe und die sagen, sorry, wir können noch nicht mal mit einem Firmenwagenupdate irgendwo was machen.
Genau, Hetze mal ICloud genutzt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird das dann wahrscheinlich auch bald nicht mehr gehen.
Na, hättest du mal iCloud genutzt, dann kannst du ja immer noch an deine Daten kommen, die das
das iPhone schiebt ja mehr oder weniger alles, weil wird nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen ist in dieser i-Cloud, ne? Also das äh wird äh das könnte halt einerseits der Weg sein, aber das ist ein, das ist dann auch echt ein sehr hoher Preis, den Apple zahlen müsste, weil.
Aber auch die Daten könnten ja irgendwann verschlüsselt sein und wenn die Leute sich halt irgendwie nicht mehr an ihre Passwörter erinnern, dann ist halt eher alles vorbei. Aber das ist auch jetzt schon äh weitgehend so.
Genau und da kommst du leider an den Punkt ähm.
Wo du vermutlich als Unternehmen mehr Kunden dadurch unglücklich machst, dass sie nie wieder an ihre Daten kommen, als du Kunden glücklich machst, dadurch, dass niemand jemals an ihre Daten kommt.
Ja, ist eine Ge.
Und.
Dass es dann auch nochmal schwierig, aber gleichzeitig werden natürlich die, wird das FBI äh jetzt nach anderen ähm rechtlichen Grundlagenmöglichkeiten
oder Präzedenzfällen suchen, um einen derartigen Zugriff zu erlauben,
Wie gesagt, es gibt diesen einen Staatsanwalt, der der ja schon sagt, der hat irgendwie hundertsiebenundzwanzig iPhones da liegen. Und das war einfach nur einer, ja.
Also das das Thema ist zu, da sind die
Interessen zu groß, als dass das Thema jetzt irgendwie mit diesem einzelnen Fall erledigt würde. Und wir wissen, da wie das so ist, ne? Diejenigen, die.
Unsere Freiheit oder unsere äh Sicherheitsrechte angreifen wollen
oder unsere Privatsphäre oder unsere Freiheit angreifen wollen, die haben langen Atem und die geben sich auch mit einer Niederlage nicht zufrieden, siehe äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Äh siehe ähnliche Gesetzgebung
Ne, also die.
Ja, aber ich würde würde auch nicht ausschließen wollen, dass dieser Fall auch, sagen wir mal, für für das Government in den USA auch einen interessanten Lehreffekt mitgebracht hat,
Weil ich glaube, dass eben viele insbesondere das FBI an der Stelle sehr blauäugig an diese Sache rangegangen ist und sie einfach gar nicht wussten, wovon sie reden.
Und das ist eben sehr wohl auch große Teile gibt und ich vermute die zum Beispiel bei einer NSA die eben äh sehr wohl weiß, wie wichtig diese Krypto ist,
Weil was heißt denn das jetzt, wenn irgendwie für das US-Government eben so einen Zugang ermöglicht werden müsse? Also abgesehen davon, dass das dann der moralische Freibrief ist für äh China äh et cetera da auch in die Vollen zu gehen,
ne? Oder im Prinzip auch im Nachgang, weil sie eben teilweise genau solche äh Dinge wahrscheinlich schon längst tun. Ja, aber im Prinzip äh liefern sie halt damit eben auch die amerikanischen Unternehmen äh,
quasi diesen anderen äh Ländern halt einfach äh eine kostenlose Backdor.
Und da gibt es dann einfach auch eine ganze Menge und der Executives äh in in großen Unternehmen mit viel Einfluss und mit viel äh Lobbyzahlung. Die laufen halt auch mit dem iPhone rum und die rufen da an und sagen,
Hallo so. Bitte? Was wollt ihr tun? Habt ihr sie noch alle? Also das ist schon äh.
Ich denke, ich denke, dass das schon eine sehr lehrreiche äh äh Geschichte war und ähm dass der nächste Ansatz nicht so plump sein kann.
Und sich auf was anderes bezieht. Ich denke mal.
Ja, ja, der wird nicht so plump sein, aber so.
Wird noch ein bisschen dauern und wird etwas anders riechen das nächste Mal.
Genau.
Lass uns äh voranschreiten.
Ja äh eine der letzten Sendungen hieß ja auch Schatz, reißte mir mal den Terrorteil.
Da ist schon eine interessante Sachen drin.
Der Terrorteil war in den letzten Wochen wieder ähm prall gefüllt. Wir hatten,
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken, dass ich da keinen vergesse. Also wir hatten, glaube ich, ähm den äh Terroranschlag in.
Istanbul und dann.
Jetzt ein ein Anschlag in Brüssel die beiden waren jetzt so am Medialpräsentesten, wobei es natürlich auch
sicherlich noch weitere in verschiedenen Orten gab, zum Beispiel zu Ostern in Pakistan
ähm wo jemand äh auch irgendwie eine eine ganze Reihe Menschen ähm mit einer Explosion getötet hat und äh wie das immer so ist, äh wenn Terror ist, dann muss
müssen die Innenpolitiker vor die Kamera treten und erklären wie sie dem jetzt ein Ende bereiten werden in Zukunft.
Und da hat sich jetzt äh Bundesinnenminister Thomas dem Maisier äh,
direkt dann zu geäußert. Ich glaube noch am Tag des äh Brüsselers äh Brüsseler Terroranschlages ähm mit den Worten Datenschutz ist schön, aber in Krisenzeiten wie diesen hat Sicherheit Vorrang.
Ähm an den Außengrenzen des Schengenraumes sind zu viele Lücken,
Wir brauchen ein Ein- und Ausreiseregister für den Schengenraum
es wäre also so, dass es im Moment getrennte Datenköpfe der verschiedenen Sicherheitsbehörden in Europa
gäbe und äh diese müssten äh verknüpft werden und auch mehr Informationen zwischen den Geheimdiensten und äh Polizeien transferiert werden.
Ja. Damit stellt er sich dann so in die in eine Reihe mit äh Hans-Peter Friedrich, der ja äh zweitausenddreizehn
die Sicherheit zum Supergrundrecht ernannte vor dem alle anderen Grundrechte zurückweichen müssen.
Ähm das äh ist natürlich wirklich ziemlich äh ziemlich schwach.
Ich finde das auch immer wieder interessant, wie sie äh sagen so, na ja so Grundrechte sind ja super, aber doch bitte nicht in Ausnahmesituationen.
Wobei das ja nun alle einfach mal genau das sind eben sozusagen genau die Momente für die Grundrechte dann eben auch wirklich mal gelten. So.
Ja, dafür sind sie geschrieben, ja.
Ne? Dass sie eben auch in Ausnahmesituationen erstmal gelten. Und deswegen muss ich auch zugeben
ich da auch seine ganze Argumentation nicht, ich weiß nicht genau, welche was da äh was da das Ventil ist oder ob die wirklich sich einfach von der ganzen Datenschutzfraktion dermaßen in die Mangel genommen fühlen, dass sie irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr klarkommen.
Es ist ja nun hier.
Gerade Brüssel und über was anderes wurde ja eigentlich in der deutschen Politik so jetzt nicht geredet, ne? Also es war jetzt nicht der Anschlag in Istanbul oder gar in Lahore, irgendwie jetzt relevant.
Es ist ja hier so offensichtlich, dass dass hier einfach mal überhaupt gar kein Datenschutzproblem bestand. Und hier bestand auch kein, kein kein.
Überwachungsproblem oder kein kein Kompetenzproblem oder so, sondern das einzige Kompetenzproblem bestand da drin.
Dass dass die Polizeiarbeit einfach nicht funktioniert hat. All diese ganzen Attentäter waren bekannt.
War gewarnt. Man hatte die auf der Liste, sogar die Amerikaner hatten die auf ihrer Nofly-Zon äh Nofly-List.
Also es ist nicht so, dass dass sie jetzt da äh es mit Unbekannten Getan zu tun getan zu tun.
Hätten und man ist schon wieder zu früh. Und ähm.
Ja, deswegen kann man das auch glaube ich einfach mal beiseite legen, oder? Die Diskussion oder warum es jetzt noch groß war, sein Zitat aufregen.
Nee, ich fand interessant, dass er dann wirklich öffentlich gut einen auf den Sack bekommen hat. Ähm von hat ausgerechnet Matthias Töpfner,
Chef des Axel-Springer-Konzerns und jetzt nicht unbedingt bekannt dafür, dass er eine besonders hohe Meinung vom Datenschutz.
Und äh der veröffentlichte dann irgendwie in der in der Welt dann einen Beitrag, in dem er dann sagte, das ist,
dieser Satz aus dem Mund des Ministers ein Skandal und ein Offenbarungsaltes Rechtsstaats ist, denn wenn man schon wenige Stunden nach dem jüngsten Anschlag.
Den Rechtsstaat mehr oder weniger über Bord wirft, dann hätten die Terroristen genau in dieser Sekunde gewonnen.
Sagte der Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken, oder?
Sagte, wer der Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken, Matthias Döffner.
Unglaublich.
So und ging dann noch weiter, sagte der Datenschutz ist keine dekorative Gelande unserer Demokratie, sie ist ein Kernelement unserer Werteordnung.
Und in der digitalen Realität ist es ja ist dieses wichtiger denn je und schützt den einzelnen vor Zugriffen auf seine Privatsphäre und Verhaltensweisen. Durch unbefugte Dritte seien es große Konzerne oder Regierungen,
und da hat er ein sehr äh spannenden oder sehr wahren Satz gesagt ohne Datenschutz gedeiht, dass Totalitäre.
Ja also.
Wahre Worte hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Öffner verlinke.
Ja. Ja, wobei man ja auch irgendwie ähm dem Springer, dem Axelspringer Verlag.
Immerhin noch lassen muss, dass zumindest der Gründer ja nun auch sehr beseelt war von der Haltung der Freiheit. Ob nun die Gründung der Bild-Zeitung an der Stelle ähm,
sehr hilfreich dabei war, das kann man sicherlich nochmal lang und breit diskutieren.
Aber wenn äh Vorstandsvorsitzende des Unternehmens zumindest zu solchen Schlüssen kommen, zwischendurch, dann ist vielleicht noch nicht alles verloren.
Ja, also ja, spannend, äh ich meine, es ist das äh man man hört und staunt, wenn man sich sowas anschaut, ja. Tja.
Terror halt. Das war der Terrorteil.
Das war der Terrorteil.
Sonst ist da jetzt so äh netzpolitisch glaube ich nicht so viel drin für uns.
Der wird da wird jetzt noch lange Zeit netzpolitisch irgendwas drauf bezogen werden. Also wir werden auf diese äh Vorkommnisse immer wieder ähm Bezug nehmen müssen.
Das ist äh einfach so, dass solche ähm,
solche Themen einerseits natürlich auch von den Hardlinern ähm ausgeschlachtet werden.
Also wir haben ja dann da äh die sprichwörtlichen äh Oles und äh so.
Die sich dann da eben äh zu zu Wort melden und dann ihre Stunde gekommen sehen. Und wir haben,
eben auch eine Bevölkerung, die dann da steht und sagt, jetzt muss aber ne, irgendwas muss jetzt sein. Und eine Bevölkerung, die sagt,
jetzt muss etwas geschehen. Äh das haben wir jetzt an anderer äh politischer Stelle, die nicht,
oder noch nicht zum Netzpolitischen gehört äh in den letzten Wochen bei den Wahlen gesehen, wie
Bevölkerungsgruppen reagieren und agieren. Die meinen jetzt müsste mal was geschehen. Nicht nur bei den Wahlen haben wir das übrigens gesehen, sondern auch davor,
Insofern ist natürlich ein äh Bundesinnenminister in der dummen Situation dann, in der da irgendetwas sagen zu müssen, um den Eindruck zu vermitteln, man habe eine Ursache.
Ermittelt und arbeite an ihrer Behebung.
Ja, ich freue mich vor allem, von welchem Terror redet der jetzt eigentlich gerade
Also ich meine Brüssel hin, Brüssel her, das ist in einem anderen Land, das mag relativ nah dran sein und mit uns viel zu tun haben, gar keine Frage
Aber äh haben wir nicht gerade irgendwie so ein bisschen eher das Problem, dass wir so einen Rechtsterror haben, der irgendwie äh überall Flüchtlingsheime anzündet und das irgendwie jetzt schon so in die dreistellige Zahl äh hineingeht, mit einer Aufklärungsquote von,
zehn bis zwanzig Prozent, wenn überhaupt.
Zehn bis zwanzig Prozent äh ist nicht die Aufklärungsquote, sondern die Wahlergebnisse der AfD.
Also, wenn es überhaupt eine Aufklärungsquote gibt, dann ist sie sehr gering. Und ähm ich finde das immer wieder interessant, wie.
Nicht davon gesprochen wird.
Ja? Also ich meine, man kann ja gerne eine Terrordiskussion führen. Man kann auch gerne eine Diskussion darüber führen, wie man äh da am besten rangeht. Aber ich habe eher so den Eindruck, es wird halt einfach in der äh Hinsicht einfach überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Also man hat.
Ja, natürlich nicht. Das ist ja auch kein Problem.
Da sind ja keine Menschen betroffen, äh die eine Wahlberechtigung hätten.
Ja hm beunruhigend. Herr Innenminister, da wüsste ich ja gerne mal äh was eigentlich damit ist.
Also das ist aber ne, ich meine mit diesen mit diesen Arschlöchern vom IS muss man sich jetzt auch darauf gefasst machen äh dass wir äh noch das ein oder andere Mal ähm.
Mit äh Terroranschlägen äh.
In dem Bereich zu tun haben, werden den wir uns, den wir irgendwie wertschätzen, ja? Bei anderen Bereichen ist das ja auch immer noch mal was anderes. Ändert unsere Politik ja nichts mit zu tun, aber das heißt eben auch, dass wir,
dass man da jetzt eben äh ja.
Die Stärke und die Überlegenheit der äh der Demokratie, des Rechtsstaats und der Freiheit,
eben auch mit mit Stolz und Würde zeigen muss.
Das ist eben das, was der Dörfner hier auch zu Recht kritisiert, dass es eben äh das Entwürdigende an dieser an dieser völlig bescheuerten Schnellschussreaktion von äh,
von dem Maisier, die selbstverständlich nicht.
In irgend in irgendeiner Analyse begründet ist oder so. Das ist einfach nicht der Fall.
Ja gut, aber Dipschnap muss ich auch sagen, Butter bei Fische. Ich meine, die die Bildhaltung war dann auch wieder dabei, irgendwie den den Terrorkrieg auszurufen, et cetera und das Ganze einfach mal wieder auszuschlachten und zu behöhen
in einem Maße, wie man eben dann auch einfach ähm wo es einem auf auf schwer gemacht wird
so 'ne Diskussion auch mal auf einer stabilen Grundlage zu führen, ja? Äh ich mein bin ein großer Freund davon, dass man das irgendwie versucht so ähm.
Sagen, so cool wie möglich zu diskutieren und so zu sagen, ich meine, ich verstehe ja, dass dass ein Terroranschlag hat, deswegen werden sie ja auch gemacht,
die ähm erzeugen einfach eine Angst vor dem Ungewissen,
ja? Da kann man noch tausendmal äh argumentieren, dass ja mehr Leute im Straßenverkehr umkommen. Da wissen die Leute zumindest, ich bin jetzt im Straßenverkehr und jetzt könnte es passieren. Und wenn ich dann zu viel Angst habe, dann lasse ich's halt sein mit dem Straßenverkehr
findet auch nicht statt, aber das ist irgendwie eine konkrete Moment so, aber dieses egal wo ich bin, überall könnte es passieren, ja,
und ich kann mich dann auch nicht dagegen wehren, ich kann auch nicht mit meiner eigenen,
Fahrexpertise oder Vorsicht irgendwie äh dazu beitragen, ja? Das ist halt das, was irgendwie ähm an der Stelle wirkt. Und da so,
cool zu bleiben und zu sagen, na ja, guckt euch doch mal die Zahlen an, Terror geht seit den achtziger Jahren enorm zurück.
Wir haben zwar so eine Wahrnehmung, dass gerade viel wäre, tatsächlich ist noch nie so wenig.
Passiert, es gibt immer mal wieder diese Ausreißer, wer eben jetzt mit Brüssel und mit Paris aber so im Mittel ist das,
doch im Prinzip alles auf einem guten Weg und auch der Kampf gegen den IS oder da ist, wie man jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen soll, wenn man PC ist. Ähm.
Ist ja eigentlich auch auf einem guten Weg. Und klar, jetzt wird's wahrscheinlich nochmal passieren, irgendein Trottel wird sich wahrscheinlich nochmal irgendwo in die Luft springen und wenn wir Pech haben, ist es halt in Deutschland und dann bin ich auch mal gespannt, äh ob Herr Düpfner dann immer noch mit seiner selben Position,
auftritt.
Ja. Nun wenden wir uns.
Wenden wir uns der schönen T und der Abmahnindustrie.
Ja
Da gibt es jetzt eine Petition.
Die sich an Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel.
Und drei weitere Personen wendet, die ich aber erst nach dem Link sehe, was sind die anderen drei. Steht hier auch nicht.
Ja, also an an äh Sigmar Gabriel errichtet warum ist warum.
Ja okay. Also Online-Petition, das ist ja immer so, ah, hier sind sie, Mitglieder, also
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel, Mitglieder des Bundestagsausschusses Wirtschaft und Energie, netzpolitische Sprecher der CDU CSU, SPD-Regierungskoalition sowie an das Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft,
Energie und in dieser Petition ähm wird das Ende der Abmahnindustrie verlangt.
Ähm und wie wir wissen, ist die Abmahnindustrie tatsächlich auch so ein ein ja
die durch die WLAN-Störerhaftung besonders begünstigt in in Deutschland.
Und ähm hat weiterhin hier den fürchterlichen Nachteil, äh dass wir darunter leiden kein WLAN zu haben. Also ich bin ja.
Immer mal wieder unterwegs in anderen Städten.
Und anderen Ländern und da hast du eigentlich, egal wo du hingehst, irgendwie ein offenes WLAN, ne? In jeder, in jedem,
lokal in jeder,
auf der offenen Straße, ja, gerade irgendwie hatte ich ja erwähnt, Salzburg, da gehst du da auf diese Salzburg, das ist nun wirklich ein etwas älteres Gebäude,
Die haben da natürlich WLAN für dich. Gratis und.
Nun gibt es diese Petition, die also sagt, okay, es wäre,
Im Moment stehen die Chancen nämlich eigentlich ganz gut, äh, die europäische Kommission, der Bundesrat, diverse Verbände und sogar jetzt zuletzt der Alexander Dobrindt haben irgendwie mal erkannt.
Dass wahrscheinlich irgendwie mehr der Gesellschaft schadet als ihr bringt.
Und deswegen gibt's jetzt hier eine Petition von Christian Heise gegen,
die Störerhaftung und das reizt sich also in ein großes Gefüge ein und da sei.
Darum gebeten, dass diese jetzt zu zeichnen.
Auf Change Dot Org.
Auf Change Dot Org, Link ist gegeben. Und die steht auch schon gar nicht so schlecht, die steht,
kurz vor dem fünfunddreißigtausend Personen Meilenstein,
läuft, da sollte man also da tut man sich auch nicht weh, das ist ja immer so. Man kriegt dann halt eine lange Zeit noch Spam von Change Dot org und muss den irgendwie aussortieren, aber äh ist ja ein kleiner Preis.
Ist auf jeden Fall der richtige Zeitpunkt, weil ähm ja jetzt auch äh Zweifel aufgekommen sind. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, ob ihr die Entscheidung oder die anstehende Entscheidung des EUGH, das hattet ihr kurz beleuchtet, ne, beim letzten Mal.
Ich glaube sogar beim vorletzten Mal, wo wir die Meinung des Generalanwaltes äh zitiert hatten, oder? Das ist doch das, was du meinst.
Nee, das muss äh müssten du und Thomas äh geleistet haben. Ich äh schaue mal kurz,
genau, ja das hattet ihr letztes Mal und mittlerweile ist es ja sogar so, dass unser toller Verkehrs und inoffizieller Internetminister Nummer drei,
Herr Dobrindt, äh jetzt auch schon so drauf eingestiegen ist, dass es dann vielleicht auch mit der Störerhaftung mal nicht so eine gute Idee ist.
Die Sache kommt in Bewegung gerade, weil sie sehen halt jetzt, wenn sie auf europäischer Ebene verlieren und danach sieht's ja aus, müssen sie ohnehin.
Alles wegschmeißen, was sie gerade so,
am Start haben, an Gesetzesentwürfen, also zumindest mit diesen Einschränkungen kann natürlich sein, dass diese ganze Portal Clicknummer dann äh immer noch dabei ist. Gucken wir mal,
wie das ausgeht. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl das ist jetzt so, das stirbt,
Wir werden Ende dieses Jahres da einfach Fortschritte erzielt haben, aber es ist sicherlich genau auch jetzt gut, da nochmal ordentlich drauf zu kloppen, dass eben dann mit dieser anstehenden Änderung auch die
eine eine ordentliche Formulierung gefunden wird, womit dann das Thema einfach auch erstmal durch ist.
Ja und eine weitere Initiative, wo man wir hatten sie äh auch vor mehreren Sendungen schon angesprochen, ist die äh EU-Direktive äh zu dem,
zu den Funksignalen, äh die im Mai zweitausendvierzehn äh ohne besonderes äh besondere Aufmerksamkeit der Öffentlichkeit äh verabschiedet wurde, in der es mehr oder weniger heißt, ein
EU-Staat muss äh Gesetze haben nationale Gesetze haben.
Die ist mehr oder weniger erzwingen, dass äh Geräte, die mit Wifi äh Funknetzen oder GPS äh irgendwie zu tun haben, nicht so einfach mit einer anderen,
äh Software versehen werden können. Also Radio Equipment, Shelt Support,
Moment, ich kenne das jetzt gerade nicht so einfach zu übersetzen, aber dass man, also sie wollen im Prinzip sicherstellen, dass keine Drittanbieter-Software
freie Drittanbieter-Software darauf gespielt werden kann und das hat eben äh das Problem für freie Software an sich. Wir haben ein sehr großes, äh, tolles
und gut funktionierendes WLAN äh Access Point und guter Projekt namens Open Warte, auf dem dann eben äh auch Freifunk aufsetzt und viele andere. Es hat äh schlechte Folgen für den We
da ja hier dann Software an Geräte gebunden wird beziehungsweise Geräte an Software,
Es hat schlechte Folgen wie für Innovation und irgendwie auch eine
dauerhafte Nutzbarkeit von Geräten und natürlich auch ein großes Problem für die Sicherheit von Geräten, weil oft bei den günstigen Herstellern eben auch Schrott
Software drauf ist, all das hatten wir schon besprochen. Da gibt es also jetzt auch eine ähm Initiative breit aufgestellt, der
Free Software Foundation Europe und der kann man sich.
Anschließen. Bisher wird die getragen von äh dem Cars Computerclub Freifunk Punkt net
äh Toppoint und der Open Net in und da ist äh freut freut sich die Free Software Foundation Europe,
die das Ding ins Leben gerufen hat. Wenn da weitere Organisationen, ja, mitmachen.
Ja damit denke ich kommen wir langsam äh ans Ende, ne
Gut, dass es uns äh äh noch nicht so geht wie Microsoft, dass wir äh,
durch den ganzen äh politischen Widerstand anfangen selber komplett äh durchzudrehen und den merkwürdigsten Schlussfolgerungen zu kommen
was ja sicherlich äh äh mitbekommen, wie das äh arme kleine äh Internetbot Mädchen Thai äh verwirrt wurde von Treuen.
Ja, was war da los? Sie haben einen Twitterbot äh irgendwie eine eine Artificial Intelligence twittern lassen, ne? Und nach einem nach einem Tag war sie Hitler.
Na am Tag war sie Hitler und es ist insofern auch ganz interessant, als dass sie wohl, also sie meinten zumindest, äh das wäre jetzt gar nicht so komplett neu entwickelt worden, sondern sie hätten das jetzt nur auf die bessere westliche Zivilisation losgelassen. Sie hätten,
ähnliches System schon eine Weile. In China wohl verhältnismäßig erfolgreich ähm getestet. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wieso die.
Gepflogenheiten sind, ähm offensichtlich scheint es nicht ganz so übel zu sein, wie in der westlichen Welt. Hier allerdings kam halt,
Teig quasi so als Twitter, Persona online, wo du halt groß angekündigt und gesagt, so hier und redet mit euch und toll und wir lernen auch die ganze Zeit weiter. Und dann kam halt irgendwie so allerlei gassiges Volk.
Und äh redete auf sie ein und es dauerte dann halt irgendwie keine vierundzwanzig Stunden und
auf einmal war sie dann halt einfach nur noch irgendwie im Hitler-Modus und Juden müssen vergast werden und überhaupt alles ist einfach äh also es war sozusagen, also am Vollanschlag, ja, Feminismus ist irgendwie auch äh äh
überhaupt das Schlimmste der Welt und äh äh was nicht alles. Also es war sozusagen so wirklich so so Gamer-Gate und AfD in einer Person zusammengequirlt und äh brüllte sozusagen dann ihre frisch erworbenen Meinungen
auch schön breit ins Internet raus. War natürlich eine riesen Katastrophe für äh Microsoft PR mäßig.
Ja, kugel schlicht irgendwie den den Weltmeister im im Go und Microsoft hast die Juden äh und die Feministinnen sollen alle in der Feminist.
Soll alle sterben und in der Hölle schmoren. Ja, wunderbar.
Ja, also da da geht der Punktsieg auf jeden Fall an äh Google. Wobei ich ja auch nochmal über diese Alphago Geschichte nachgedacht habe mit einem ganz interessanten Punkt
Weil es wird ja jetzt so viel darüber geschrieben, dass ja sozusagen die künstliche Intelligenz und so viel toller sei als die menschliche Intelligenz, weil man hat ja jetzt sozusagen die Experten in Go geschlagen.
Und dann muss ich sagen, in gewisser Hinsicht.
Klar hatten wir ja auch besprochen, ist das alles ein ganz interessantes und wir stehen vor einer neuen Zeit. Ich frage mich nur, wie gut hätte das Ding abgeschnitten.
Wenn es zumindest in den letzten zwei Wochen der Vorbereitung oder wenigstens an dem Tag des Spiels während des Spiels dieselbe Energieaufnahme.
Für beide Kontrahenten gegeben hätten. Weil ich meine, der wird ja wahrscheinlich sich im Wesentlichen nur von ein paar Eiern und ähm.
Bisschen Speck und keine Ahnung, Tomaten, was weiß ich, was der so äh alles zum Frühstück hatte äh ernährt haben. Und das ist sozusagen der Energie äh Vorrat, den sein Gehirn abgebraten hat,
Also wir reden wahrscheinlich hier nur wenige tausend Kalorien,
während ich vermute, dass dieser Supercluster von Alpha Go deutlich mehr äh Energiezufuhr gehabt hat,
Und das finde ich so ein bisschen unfair.
Aber der Mensch der.
Also das wäre jetzt mal interessant, da kenne ich mich nicht gut genug aus. Äh das ist zu lange her, dass es in mein Physik-Ekat ich äh sowas nochmal irgendwie rechnen konnte. Ähm.
Was hat denn dieser Mensch in der Lernzeit an Energie verbraten.
Also man müsste echt mal die Ökobilanz des menschlichen äh Gospelers, ne? Was hat der an Eiern in seiner Lebenszeit oder von mir aus auch nur in der Lernzeit ähm gegessen.
Vielleicht ist der auch Veganer oder ne oder Fleischesser kann auch sein. Ähm und wie viel ähm,
wie viel Sonnen, äh, wie viel Tage Sonne oder wie viele Tage Atomkraftwerke hat diese AI von Google verbraten, äh, bis sie soweit war, den schlagen zu können. Das wäre doch dann der faire Vergleich.
Das wäre der faire Vergleich und äh auf der Basis sollten sie sich mal messen lassen. Also das äh wäre tatsächlich wenn sie das schaffen mit dem selben Energiebedarf den zu schlagen.
Dann sage ich, okay, I welcome, mine overlords. Aber bis dahin sage ich fake.
Ja, wenn sie dich nicht vorher äh vergasen oder so okay.
Genau. Schick einen Tai auf meinen Hals.
Das ist ja aber ach ja. Ach Microsoft, sie können einem auch echt leid tun. Also was die irgendwie.
Ja, sie können einem leid tun, aber äh das Tool, was wir gerade von ihnen hier benutzen, um diese Sendung zu machen, das ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen audisch
Also das war jetzt mal wieder eine Sendung unter schwierigen Bedingungen. Ich hoffe äh es ist nicht zu sehr durchgedrungen zu euch ähm Hörerinnen und Hörern
aber ich glaube nächste Woche sind wir dann mal wieder äh nicht so weit voneinander getrennt, oder?
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, ich muss mal in den Kalender gucken, aber wir können auf jeden Fall an dieser Stelle noch äh Henrik und Thorsten danken.
Das machen wir. Ja, und ich denke äh äh danke auch allen. Ich danke vor allem auch allen, das wollte ich jetzt gegen Ende auch nochmal kurz äh erwähnen.
Die schon meiner, meinem neuen Community-Projekt beigetreten sind. Schaut mal auf Meterebene Punkt M E.
Ich habe äh so auf Basis von Slack ein Fettsystem aufgesetzt, wo ich jetzt sozusagen,
Alle Hörerinnen und Hörer und mit Podcaster et cetera äh einlade dort äh ja etwas näher miteinander zu diskutieren, als man das vielleicht bisher über Twitter oder andere Kanäle gemacht hat.
Und ja, das ist ähm ein Versuch
ich bin selber sehr gespannt, wie der so ausgeht und ja, wenn ihr Lust habt, so ein bisschen mehr Tufelung aufzunehmen, es gibt auch für Lokbuch Netzpolitik einen entsprechenden Chatkanal, wo man diskutieren kann und äh ja, seid ihr herzlich eingeladen.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, das war's.
Muss ich jetzt hier chatten oder was.
Du? Nö, du musst gar nichts.
Aber okay, ich bin mal gespannt, ich gucke mir das an, wie man das checken kann.
Ich hätte dann mit. Ich habe, ich mache da eine AID, die für mich chatte.
Ciao, ciao.